[Music]
the Senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will lead us in
prayer let us pray
arise O Lord as we enter the final
arguments phase of this impeachment
trial mighty God we continue to keep our
eyes on you on who our faith depends
from start to finish
may our senators embrace your promise to
do for them immeasurably abundantly
above all that they can ask or imagine
lord help our lawmakers to store your
promises in their hearts and permit you
to keep them from stumbling grant that
they will leave a legacy of Honor as
they seek your will in all they do we
pray in your amazing name amen please
join me in reciting the pledge of
allegiance
no objection the journal of proceedings
of the trial are approved to date the
deputy sergeant in arms will make the
proclamation hear ye hear ye
hearing all persons are commanded to
keep silence on pain of imprisonment
while the Senate of the United States is
sitting for the trials of the articles
of impeachment exhibited by the House of
Representatives against Donald John
Trump President of the United States
Chief Justice the majority leader is
recognized colleagues today the Senate
will hear up to four hours of closing
statements by the two sides will take a
30-minute lunch break after the house
has made its initial presentation then
we'll come back and finish this
afternoon pursuant to the provisions of
Senate resolution 488 the Senate has
provided for up to four hours of closing
arguments equally divided between the
managers on the part of the House of
Representatives and counsel and the
counsel for the president pursuant to
rule 22 of the rules of procedure and
practice in the Senate when sitting on
impeachment trials the arguments shall
be opened and closed on the part of the
House of Representatives the presiding
officer recognizes mr. managers shift to
begin the presentation on the part of
the House of Representatives mr. Chief
Justice members of the US Senate Council
for the President almost 170 years ago
Senator Daniel Webster of Massachusetts
took to the well of the old Senate
chamber not far from where I'm standing
he delivered what would become perhaps
his most famous address the 7th of March
speech Webster sought to rally his
colleagues to adopt the compromise of
1850 a package of legislation that he
and others hoped would forestall a civil
war brewing over the question of slavery
he said it is fortunate that there is a
Senate of the United States a body not
yet moved from its propriety not lost to
a just sense of its own dignity and its
own high responsibilities and a body to
which the country looks with confidence
for wise moderate patriotic and healing
councils it is not to be denied that we
live in the midst of strong agitations
and are surrounded by very considerable
dangers to our institutions of
government the imprisoned winds are let
loose but I have a duty to perform and I
mean to perform it with fidelity not
without a sense of surrounding dangers
but not without hope Webster was wrong
to believe that the compromise of 1850
could prevent succession of the south
but I hope he was not wrong to put his
faith in the Senate because the design
of the Constitution and the intention of
the framers was that the Senate would be
a chamber removed from the sway of
temporary political winds in Federalist
sixty-five Hamilton wrote quote where
else than in the Senate could have been
found a tribunal sufficiently dignified
or sufficiently independent what other
body would be likely to feel confidence
enough in its own situation to preserve
an odd and uninfluenced the necessary
impartiality between an individual
accused and the representatives of the
people his accusers in the same essay
Hamilton explained this about
impeachment the subjects of its
jurisdiction are those offenses which
proceeded from the misconduct of public
men
or in other words from the abuse or
violation of some public trust they are
of a nature which may with peculiar
peculiar propriety be dominated
political as they really chiefly to
injuries done immediately to the society
itself the prosecution of them for this
reason will seldom fail to agitate the
passions of the whole community and to
divide it into parties more or less
friendly or animal to the accused in
such cases there will always be the
greatest danger that the decision will
be regulated more by the comparative
strength of parties than by the real
demonstrations of innocence or guilt
Daniel Webster and Alexander Hamilton
placed their hopes in you the Senate to
be the court of greatest impartial 'ti
to be a neutral representative of the
people in determining uninfluenced by
party or pre-existing faction the
innocence or guilt of the President of
the United States today you have a duty
to perform with fidelity not without a
sense of surrounding dangers but also
not without hope I submit to you on
behalf of the House of Representatives
that your duty demands that you convict
President Trump now I don't pretend that
this is an easy process it's not
designed to be easy it shouldn't be easy
to impeach or convict a president
impeachment is an extraordinary remedy a
tool only to be used in rare instances
of grave misconduct but it is in the
Constitution for a reason in America no
one is above the law
even those elected president of the
United States and I would say especially
those elected president of the United
States you've heard arguments from the
President's Council that impeachment
would overturn the results of the 2016
election you have heard that in seeking
the removal and disqualification of the
president the house is seeking to
interfere in the next election senators
neither is true and these arguments
demonstrated deeply misguided or I think
intentional
effort to mislead about the role that
impeachment plays and our democracy if
you believe as we do and as we have
proven that the president's efforts to
use his official powers that cheat in
the 2020 election jeopardize our
national security and are antithetical
to our democratic tradition then you
must come to no other conclusion that
the president threatens the fairness of
the next election and risk putting
foreign in her flute interference
between the voters and their ballots
professor Dershowitz and the other
counselors to the president have argued
that if the president thinks that
something is in his interest than it is
by definition in the interests of the
American people we have said throughout
this process that we cannot and should
not leave our common sense at the door
the logical conclusion this argument is
that the president is the state that his
interests are the nation's interests
that his will is necessarily ours you
and I and the American people know
otherwise if we do not have to be
constitutional scholars to understand
that this is a position deeply at odds
with our Constitution and our democracy
that believing in this argument or
allowing the President to get away with
misconduct based on this extreme extreme
view would render him above the law well
we know that this cannot be true what
you decide on these articles will have
lasting implications for the future of
the presidency not only for this
president but for all future presidents
whether or not the office of the
presidency of the United States of
America is above the law that is the
question as Alexis de Tocqueville wrote
in his 1835 work democracy in America
quote the greatness of America lies not
and being made more enlightened than any
other nation but rather in her ability
to repair her faults in May of 1974
Barry Goldwater and other Republican
congressional leaders went to the White
House to tell President Nixon
it was time for him to resign and that
they could no longer hold back the tide
of impeachment over Watergate now
contrary to popular belief the
Republican Party did not abandon Nixon
as the Watergate scandal came to light
it took years of disclosures in crisis
and court battles the parties stood with
Nixon through Watergate because he was a
popular conservative president and his
base was with him so they were too but
ultimately as Goldwater would tell Nixon
quote there are only so many lies you
can take and now there have been one too
many the president would have us believe
that he did not withhold aid of course
these sham investigations that is July
25th call with the Ukrainians was
perfect that his meeting with President
szalinski and the sidelines of the UN is
no different than a head of state
meeting in the Oval Office that his only
interest in having Ukraine announce
investigations into the Biden's was an
altruistic concern over corruption that
the Ukrainians interfered in our 2016
election not Russia that Putin knows
better than our own intelligence
agencies how many falsehoods
can we take when will it be one too many
let us take a few minutes to remind you
one last time though the facts of the
president's misconduct as you consider
how you'll vote on this important matter
for our nation those facts compel the
president's conviction on the two
articles of impeachment
mr. Chief Justice and senators over the
past two weeks the house has presented
to you overwhelming and unconverted
evidence that President Trump has
committed grave abuses of power that
harmed our national security and were
intended to defraud our elections
president Trump abused the extraordinary
powers he alone holds as president of
the United States to coerce an ally to
interfere in our upcoming presidential
election for the benefit of his own
re-election he then used those unique
powers to wage an unprecedented campaign
to obstruct convert Congress and cover
up his wrongdoing as the president
schemed to corrupt our election
progressed over several months it became
as one witness described more insidious
the president and his agents wielded the
powers of the presidency and the full
weight of the US government to increase
pressure on Ukraine's new President to
coerce him to announce to sham
investigations that was smear his
potential election opponent and raise
his political standing by early
September of last year the president's
pressure campaign appeared on the verge
of succeeding until that is the
president got caught and the scheme was
exposed in response President Trump
ordered a massive cover-up unprecedented
in American history he tried to conceal
the facts from Congress using every tool
and legal window-dressing he could to
block evidence and muzzle witnesses he
tried to prevent the public from
learning how he placed himself above
country and yet even as president Trump
has orchestrated this cover-up and
obstructed Congress's impeachment
inquiry he remains unapologetic
unrestrained
intent on continuing his sham to defraud
our elections as I stand here today
delivering the houses closing argument
president Trump's constitutional crimes
his crimes against the American people
and the nation remain in progress as you
make your final determination on the
president's guilt it is therefore worth
revisiting the totality of the
president's misconduct doing so lays
bare the ongoing threat
president Trump poses to our democratic
system of government both to our
upcoming election that some suggest
should be the arbiter of the president's
misconduct and to the Constitution
itself that we all swore to support and
defend Donald Trump was the central
player in the corrupt scheme assisted
principally by his private attorney Rudy
Giuliani early in 2019
Giuliani conspired with to corrupt
former Ukrainian prosecutors to
fabricate and promote phony
investigations of wrongdoing by former
Vice President Joe Biden as well as the
Russian propaganda that it was Ukraine
not Russia that hacked the DNC in 2016
in the course of their presentation to
you the President's Council have made
several remarkable admissions that
affirm core elements of this scheme
including specifically about Giuliani's
role and representation of the president
the president's counsel has conceded
that Giuliani sought to convince Ukraine
to investigate the Biden's and alleged
Ukraine election interference on behalf
of his client the president and that the
president's focus on these sham
investigations was significantly
informed by Giuliani
whose views the president adopted
compounding this damning admission the
President's Council has also conceded
that Giuliani was not conducting foreign
policy on behalf of the president they
have confirmed that in pursuit pursuing
these two investigations Giuliani was
working solely in the president's
private personal interest and the
president's personal interest is now
clear to cheat in the next election as
Giuliani would later admit for the
president scheme to succeed he first
needed to remove the American ambassador
to Ukraine
Murray Ivanovich an anti-corruption
champion Giuliani viewed as an obstacle
who when I quote was getting was going
to make the investigations difficult for
everybody working with now indicted
associates left harness and ego our
crewman Juliana orchestrated a bogus
month-long smear campaign against the
Ambassador that culminated in her
removal in April the president's sudden
order to remove our ambassador came just
three days after Ukraine's presidential
election in late April which saw a
reformer falada Mir of szalinski swept
into office on an anti-corruption
platform President Trump called to
congratulate Solinsky right after his
victory he invited president Solinsky to
the White House and agreed to sin vice
president Pence to his inauguration but
three weeks later after Rudy Giuliani
was denied a meeting with President
Solinsky President Trump
abruptly abruptly ordered vice president
Pence to cancel his trip instead a
lower-level delegation led by three of
president Trump's political appointees
Secretary of Energy Rick Perry
ambassador to the European Union Gordon
Sandlin
and Special Representative for Ukraine
negotiations kurt volker attended the
linseeds inauguration the following week
these three returned from Ukraine
impressed with president zalenski in a
meeting shortly thereafter with
President Trump in the Oval Office they
relayed their positive impression of the
new Ukrainian president and encouraged
President Trump to schedule the White
House meeting he promised in his first
call but president Trump reacted
negatively he railed that Ukraine tried
to take me down in 2016 and in order to
schedule a White House visit for
president Solinsky president Trump told
the delegation that they would have to
and I quote talk to Rudy it is worth
pausing here to consider the importance
of this meeting in late May this is the
moment that President Trump successfully
hijacked the tools of our government to
serve his corrupt personal interests
when the president's domestic political
errand as one witness famously described
it began to overtake and subordinate
u.s. foreign policy and national
security interests by this point in the
scheme Rudy Giuliani was advocating very
publicly for Ukraine to pursue the to
sham investigations but his request to
meet with President Solinsky was
rebuffed by the new Ukrainian president
according to reports about ambassador
Bolton's account soon to be available if
not to this body then to bookstores near
you the president also unsuccessfully
tried to get Bolton to call the new
Ukrainian president to ensure he would
meet with Giuliani the desire for
Ukraine to announce these phony
investigations was for a clear and
corrupt reason because President Trump
wanted to politically benefit wanted the
political benefit of a foreign country
announcing
would investigate his rival that is how
we know without a doubt that the object
of the president's scheme was to benefit
his re-election campaign in other words
to cheat in the next election
Ukraine resisted announcing the
investigations throughout June so the
president and his agent rudy giuliani
turned up the pressure this time by
yielding the power of the United States
government in mid-june the Department of
Defense publicly announced that it would
be releasing 250 million of military
assistance to Ukraine
almost immediately after seeing this the
president quietly ordered a freeze on
the assistance to Ukraine
none of the 17 witnesses in our
investigation were provided with a
credible reason for the whole when it
was implemented and all relevant
agencies opposed the freeze in July
Giuliani and the president's opponents
appointees made clear to Ukraine that a
meeting at the White House would only be
scheduled if Ukraine announced the sham
investigations according to a July 19
female the White House has tried to
suppress this drug deal
as ambassador Bolton called it was well
known among the president's most senior
officials including his chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney and Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo and it was relayed directly
to senior Ukrainian officials by Gordon
Sandlin on July 10 at the White House
everyone was in the loop
although President Solinsky explained
that he did not want to be a pawn in
Washington politics President Trump did
not care in fact on July 25 before
President Trump spoke to President
szalinski president personally conveyed
the terms of this quid pro quo to
Gordon's Island
who then relayed the message to
Ukraine's president later that morning
during the now-infamous phone call
president Trump explicitly requested
that Ukraine investigate the Biden's and
the 2016 election Solinsky responded as
president Trump instructed he assured
President Trump that he would undertake
these investigations after hearing this
commitment
president Trump reiterated his
invitation to the White House at the end
of the call now no later than a few days
after the call the highest levels of the
Ukrainian government learned about the
whole on military assistance senior
Ukrainian officials decided to keep it
quiet recognising the harm it would
cause to Ukraine's defense to the new
government standing at home and to his
negotiating posture with Russia
officials in Ukraine and the United
States hoped that the hole would be
reversed before it became public as we
now know that was not to be as we have
explained during the trial the
president's scheme did not begin with
the July 25th call and it did not end
there either as instructed a top aide to
president Solinsky met with Giuliani in
early August and they began working on a
press statement for Solinsky to issue
that would announce the to sham
investigations and lead to a White House
meeting now let's be very clear here the
documentary evidence alone the text
messages the emails that we've showed
you confirms definitely the president's
corrupt definitively the president's
corrupt
quid pro quo for the White House meeting
subsequent testimony further affirms
that the president was ill this official
act this highly coveted oval office
meeting to apply pressure
on Ukraine to do his personal bidding
the evidence is unequivocal
despite this pressure by mid-august
president stilinski resisted such an
explicit announcement of the two
politically motivated investigations
desired by President Trump as a result
the White House meeting remained
unscheduled just as it remains
unscheduled to this day during this same
time frame in August the president
persisted in maintaining the hole on the
aid despite warnings that he was
breaking the law by doing so as an
independent watchdog recently confirmed
that he did according to the evidence
presented to you the president's entire
cabinet believed he should release the
aide because it was in the national
security interest of our country during
the entire month of August there was no
internal review of the aid
Congress was not notified nor was there
any credible reason provided within the
executive branch with no explanation
offered and with the explicit clear yet
unsuccessful quid pro quo for the White
House meeting in the front of his mind
ambassador Sunland testified that the
only logical conclusion was that the
president was also withholding military
assistance to increase the pressure on
Ukraine to announce the investigations
at sunland and another witness testified
this conclusion was as simple as two
plus two equals four if the White House
meeting was a sufficient leverage to
extract the announcements he wanted
Trump would use the frozen aid as his
hammer secretary Pompeo confirmed
sonless conclusion in an August 22 email
it was also clear that vice president
Pence
was aware of the quid pro quo over the
aid and was directly informed of such an
wass Warsaw on September 1 after the
freeze had become public and Ukraine
became desperate Salman pulled aside a
top aide in Warsaw and told him that
everything both the White House meeting
and also the security assistant were
conditioned on the announcement of the
investigations that salman Giuliani and
others had been negotiating with the
same aide earlier in August this is an
important point the president claims
that Ukraine did not know of the freeze
in aid though we know this to be false
as the former Deputy Foreign Minister
has admitted publicly they found out
about it within days of the July 25th
call and kept it quiet but no one can
dispute that even after the all became
public on July 2 on August 28th
president Trump's representatives
continued their efforts to secure
Ukraine's announcement of the
investigations this is enough to prove
extortion in court and it is certainly
enough to prove it here if that wasn't
enough however on September 7 more than
a week after the aid freeze became
public
president Trump confirmed directly to
Saarland that he wanted president
Solinsky in a public box and that his
release of the aid was conditioned on
the announcement of the two sham
investigations haven't received direct
confirmation from President Trump Salman
relayed the President's message to
president Solinsky himself president
Solinsky could resist no longer
America's military assistant makes up
10% of his country's defense budget and
president Trump's visible lack of
support for Ukraine
harmed his leverage in negotiations with
Russia president szalinski affirmed to
silent on that same telephone call that
he would announce the investigations in
an interview on CNN president Trump's
pressure campaign appeared to have
succeeded two days after President
Solinsky for confirmed its intention to
meet president Trump's demands the House
of Representatives announced its
investigation into these very issues
shortly thereafter the Inspector General
of the intelligence community notified
the intelligence communities that the
whistleblower complaint was being
improperly handled or with improperly
withheld from Congress with the White
House knowledge in other words the
president got caught and two days later
on September 11 the president released
the aide to this day however Ukraine
still has not received all of the money
Congress has appropriated and the White
House meeting has yet to be scheduled
the identity of the whistleblower
moreover is irrelevant the house did not
rely on the whistleblowers complaint
even as it turned out to be remarkably
accurate it does not matter who
initially sounded the alarm when they
saw smoke what matters is that the
firefighters Congress were summoned and
found the blaze and we know that we did
the facts about the president's
misconduct are not seriously in dispute
as several Republican senators have
acknowledged publicly we have proved
that the president abused his power and
precisely the man are charged in article
one President Trump with
Eldar White House meeting an essential
congressionally appropriated military
assistance from Ukraine in order to
pressure Ukraine to interfere in the
upcoming presidential election on his
behalf the sham investigations president
Trump wanted announced had no legitimate
purpose and were not in the national
interests despite the president's
counsel troubling reliance on conspiracy
theories to claim the president acted in
the public interest the president was
not focused on fighting corruption in
fact he was trying to pressure Ukraine's
president to act corruptly by announcing
these baseless investigations and the
evidence makes clear that the
president's decision to withhold you
cranes military aid is not connected in
any way to purport it concerns about
corruption or burden-sharing
rather the evidence was presented to you
that was presented to you is damning
chilling disturbing and disgraceful
president Trump weaponized our
government and the vast powers entrusted
to him by the American people and the
Constitution to target his political
rival and corrupt our precious elections
subverted our national security and our
democracy in the process he put his
personal interests over those of the
country and he violated his oath of
office in the process but the
president's grave abuse of power did not
in their in conduct unparalleled in
American history
once he got caught president Trump
engaged in categorical
and indiscriminate obstruction of any
investigation into his wrongdoing he
ordered every government agency and
every official to defy the houses
impeachment inquiry and he did so for a
simple reason to conceal evidence of his
wrongdoing from Congress and the
American people the president's
obstruction was unlawful and
unprecedented but it also confirmed its
guilt innocent people don't try to hide
every document and witness especially
those that would clear them that's what
guilty people do that's what guilty
people do innocent people do everything
they can to clear their name and provide
evidence that shows that they are
innocent but it would be a mistake to
view the president's obstruction
narrowly as the President's Council have
tried to portray it the president did
not defy the houses and Pietschmann
inquiry as part of our routine
interbranch dispute or because he wanted
to protect the constitutional rights and
privileges of his presidency he did it
consistent with his vow to fight all
subpoenas the second article of
impeachment goes to the heart of our
Constitution and our democratic system
of government the framers of the
Constitution purposefully entrusted the
power of impeachment in the legislative
branch so that it may protect the
American people from a corrupt president
the president was able to undertake such
comprehensive obstruction only because
of the exceptional powers entrusted to
him by the American people and He willed
it
power to make sure Congress would not
receive a single record or a single
document related to his conduct and to
bar his closest aides from testifying
about his scheme throughout the houses
inquiry just as they did during the
trial the president's counsel offered
bad faith and meritless legal arguments
as transparent legal window dressing
intended to legitimize and justify the
president's efforts to hide evidence of
his misconduct we've explained why all
of these legal excuses hold no merit why
the houses subpoenas were valid how the
houses house appropriately exercised
it's impeachment Authority how the
president's strategy was to stall and
obstruct we've explained how the
president's after-the-fact reliance on
unfounded and in some cases brand-new
legal privileges are shockingly
transparent cover for a president
dictate a blanket obstruction we've
underscored how the president's defiance
of Congress is unprecedented in the
history of our republic and we all know
that an innocent person would eagerly
provide testimony and documents to clear
his name as the president apparently
thought he was doing mistakenly when he
released the call records of his two
telephone calls with president Solinsky
and even as the president has claimed to
be protecting the presidency remember
that the president never actually
invoked executive privilege throughout
this entire inquiry a revealing fact
given the laws prohibition on invoking
executive privilege
to Sheol wrongdoing and yet according to
the president's counsel the president is
justified and resists in the houses
impeachment inquiry they assert that the
house should have taken the president to
court to defy the obstruction the
president's argument is as shameless as
it is hypocritical the president's
counsel is arguing in this trial that
the house should have gone to court to
enforce its subpoenas while at the same
time the president's own Department of
Justice is arguing in court that the
house could not enforce the subpoenas
through the courts and you know what
remedy they say in court is available to
the house impeachment for obstruction of
Congress this is not the first time this
argument has been made
President Nixon made it to but it was
roundly rejected by the House Judiciary
Committee 45 years ago
when the committee passed an article for
obstruction of Congress for far less
serious obstruction than we have here
the committee concluded that it was
inappropriate to enforce its subpoenas
in court and as the slide shows the
committee concluded that it was
inappropriate to seek the aid of the
course to enforce its subpoenas against
the president this conclusion is based
on the constitutional provision vesting
the power of impeachment solely in the
House of Representatives and the express
denial by the framers of the
Constitution of any role for the courts
in the impeachment process again the
committee report on Nixon's articles of
impeachment
once we strip the president's
obstruction of this legal
window-dressing the consequences are as
clear as they are dire for our democracy
to condone the president's obstruction
would strike a deathblow to the
impeachment clause in the Constitution
and if Congress cannot enforce this sole
power vested in both chambers alone
the Constitution's final line of defense
against a corrupt presidency will be
eviscerated a president who can obstruct
and thwart the impeachment power becomes
unaccountable he or she is effectively
above the law and such a president is
more likely to engage in corruption
with impunity this will become the new
normal with this president and for
future generations
so where does this leave us as many of
you in this chamber have publicly
acknowledged in the past few days the
facts are not seriously in dispute we
have proved that the president committed
grave offenses against the Constitution
the question that remains is whether
that conduct warrants conviction and
removal from office should the Senate
simply accept or even condone such
corrupt conduct by a president absent
conviction and removal how can we be
assured that this president will not do
it again
if we are to rely on the next election
to judge the president's efforts to
cheat in that election how can we know
that the election will be free and fair
how can we know that every vote will be
free from foreign interference solicited
by the President himself
with President Trump the past is
prolonged
this is neither the first time that the
president solicited foreign interference
in his own election nor that the first
time that the president tried to
obstruct an investigation into his
misconduct what you will determine you
will determine you will determine
whether it will be his last as we speak
the president continues his wrongdoing
unchecked and unashamed Donald Trump
hasn't stopped trying to pressure
Ukraine to smear his opponent nor has he
stopped obstructing Congress his
political agent Rudolph Giuliani
recently returned to the scene of the
crime in Ukraine to manufacture more
dirt for his client the President of the
United States President Trump remains a
clear and present danger to our national
security and to our credibility around
the world
he is decimating our global standing as
a beacon of democracy while corrupting
of free and fair elections here at home
what is the greater protection to our
country than ensuring that we the
American people alone not some foreign
power choose our commander in chief the
American people alone to decide who
represents us in any office without
foreign interference particularly the
highest office in the land
and what could undermine our national
security more then to withhold from a
foreign li fighting a hot war against
our adversary hundreds of millions of
dollars of military ia aid
to buy sniper rifles rocket-propelled
grenade launchers radar and night-vision
goggles so that they may fight the war
over they're keeping us safe here if we
allow the president's misconduct to
stand what message do we send what
message do we send to Russia our
adversary intent on fracturing democracy
around the world what will we say to our
European allies already concerned with
this president about whether the United
States will continue to support our NATO
commitments that have been a pillar of
our foreign policy since World War two
what message do we send to our allies in
the free world and if we allow the
president's misconduct to stand what
would we say to the 68000 men and women
in uniform in Europe right now who
courageously and admirably wake up every
day ready and willing to fight for
America's Security and Prosperity for
democracy in Europe and around the world
what message do we send them when we say
America's national security is for sale
that cannot be the message we want to
send to our Ukrainian friends or our
European allies or to our children and
our grandchildren
who will inherit this precious Republic
and I'm sure it is not the message that
you wish to send to our adversaries the
late Senator John McCain was an
astounding man
a man of great principle a great patriot
he fought admirably in Vietnam and was
in prison as a PLW for over five years
refusing an offer by the North
Vietnamese to be released early because
his father was a prominent Admiral as
you all are aware senator mccain was a
great supporter of ukraine a great
supporter of europe a great supporter of
our troops senator mccain understood the
importance of this body this
distinguished body and serving the
public once saying quote glory belongs
to the act of being constant to
something greater than yourself to a
cause to your principles to the people
on whom you rely and who rely on you the
Ukrainians and the Europeans and the
Americans around the world and here at
home are watching what we do
they are watching to see what the Senate
will do and they are relying on this
distinguished body to be constant to the
principles America was founded on in
which we've tried to uphold for more
than 240 years doing the right thing and
being constant to our principles
requires a level of moral courage that
is difficult but by no means impossible
it is at moral courage shown by public
servants throughout this country and
throughout the impeachment inquiry in
the house
people like ambassador Murray Ivanovich
her decades of nonpartisan service were
turned against her in a vicious smear
campaign that reached all the way to the
president
despite this effort she decided to honor
a duly authorized congressional subpoena
and to speak the truth to the American
people for this she was the subject of
yet more smears against her career and
her character even as she testified in a
public hearing before Congress her
courage mattered
people like ambassador Bill Taylor a
West Point graduate who wears a Bronze
Star and an heir medal for valor and his
proudest honor the combat infantryman's
badge when his country called on him he
answered again and again and again in
battle in foreign affairs and in the
face of a corrupt effort by the
President to extort a foreign country
into helping his reelection campaign an
effort that ambassador Taylor rightly
believed was crazy his courage mattered
people like Lieutenant Colonel Alexander
Finn men who came to this country as a
young child fleeing authoritarianism in
Europe he could have done anything with
his life but he true chose public
service putting on a uniform and
receiving a Purple Heart after being
wounded in battle fighting courageously
in Iraq when he heard that faithful July
25th call and which the president sold
out our country for his own personal
gain Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh
reported it and later came before Cong
to speak the truth about what happened
lieutenant colonel ving men's courage
mattered to the other public servants
who came forward and told the truth in
the face of vicious smears intimidation
and White House efforts to silence you
your courage mattered you did the right
thing you did your duty no matter what
happens today or from this day forward
that courage mattered whatever the
outcome in this trial we will remain
vigilant in the house I know there are
dedicated public servants who know the
difference between right and wrong
but make no mistake these are perilous
times if we determine that the remedy
for a president who cheats in an
election is to pronounce him vindicated
and attack those who exposed his
misconduct
senators before we break I want to take
a moment to say something about the
staff who have worked tirelessly on the
impeachment inquiry and this trial for
months now there's a small army of
public servants down the hall from this
chamber in offices throughout the house
and yes in that windowless bunker in the
Capitol who have committed their lives
to this effort because they like the
managers and the American people believe
that a president free of accountability
is a danger to the beating heart of our
democracy I'm grateful to all of them
but let me mention a few Daniel Goldman
mahavatar Rihanna or Clah Patrick Boland
William Evans Patrick Fallon Sean misko
nicholas mitchell daniel noble deanna
pilipenko emily simons
suzanne grooms krista Boyd norm Eisen
Barry Burk
Joshua Matz Doug letter Sara Estelle
Ashley at en Terry McCullough dick
Meltzer and Wendy Parker some of those
staff including some singled out in this
chamber have been made to endure the
most vicious false attacks to the point
where they feel their lives have been
put at risk the attacks on them degrade
our institution and all who serve in it
you have asked me why I hired certain of
my staff and I will tell you because
they're brilliant hard-working patriotic
and the best people for the job and they
deserve better than the attacks they
have been forced to suffer members of
the Senate mr. Chief Justice I want to
close this portion of our statement by
reading you the words of our dear friend
and former colleague in the house the
late Elijah Cummings who said this on
the day that the speaker announced the
beginning of the impeachment inquiry as
elected representatives he said of the
American people we speak not only for
those who are here with us now but for
generations yet unborn our voice is
today our messages to a future we may
never see when the history books are
written about this tumultuous era
want them to show that I was among those
in the House of Representatives who
stood up to lawlessness and tyranny we
the managers are not here representing
ourselves alone or even just the house
just as you are not here making a
determination as the president's guilt
or innocence for yourselves alone now
you and we represent the American people
the ones at home and at work who are
hoping that their country will remain
what it has always believed it to be a
beacon of hope of democracy and of
inspiration to those striving around the
world to create their own more perfect
unions for those who are standing up to
lawlessness and to tyranny Donald Trump
is betrayed his o to protect and defend
the Constitution but is not too late for
us to honor ours to wield our power to
defend our democracy as President
Abraham Lincoln said at the close of his
Cooper Union address On February 27 1869
let us be slandered by from our duty by
false accusations against us nor
frightened but from it by menaces of
destruction to the government nor of
dungeons to ourselves let us have faith
that right makes might and in that faith
led us to the end dare to do our duty as
we understand it today we urge you in
the face of overwhelming evidence of the
president's guilt and knowing that if
left in office he will continue to seek
foreign interference in the next
election to vote to convict on both
articles of impeachment and to remove
from office Donald J Trump the 45th
President of the United States mr. Chief
Justice we reserve the balance of our
time
majority the majority leader is
recognized mr. chief justice colleagues
will take a 30 minute break for lunch
without objection so ordered